i'm i'm all into my body fat i hate the
way i look right now because i look like
a little
little rat that is i can't you know i
want to be bigger
the good news is we have cameras on so
everybody can see that you're not alone
you know i went like
oh well but i don't want to like take
your like i'm not going to do it but if
you were to show everyone i would i
would take my shirt off but
i think it's you know with all the
respect
in another podcast i believe that each
and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense welcome to the
pretty intense podcast
today we're talking to tony kanaan
who is an indycar driver and was a
teammate of mine
so for me i was really interested in
hearing about
him as a person in his life that's just
stuff you don't get into when you're
when you're friends you're just kind of
going about your life and your work but
i really wanted to dive into that and so
we did
so we talked about balance of that and
how to
grow as a human being to being a happier
person tony kanaan welcome to the pretty
intense podcast
thank you actually the name is pretty
intimidating
do you think that i'm a pretty intense
person yeah knowing you does it makes
sense
yeah a hundred percent it does 100 yeah
well
um i think thank you why well
well because i don't think it always
means all the best things right like
being pretty intense is
can be a little offensive at times scary
like you said scary it's yeah but that's
a good thing it's not a bad thing
sometimes it's good to be scary to
people
that's true you know like people will
back off and
they'll look at you a different way so
yeah well like
like i was just we're just saying before
we press record well let's face it i
didn't press record
um to like this is not structured this
is like a conversation
and how it's funny to get out of that
headspace of
an interview like we're so used to doing
which is
um you know this is what you gotta say
mention your sponsors make sure you plug
the race
make sure you do this and it's you know
five minutes later it's over with
if you're lucky and and this is one of
those formats where we can
talk and people can get a feel for our
personality
i've always felt like in in racing in
particular it's always been hard to
develop huge fan bases for a specific
driver because
it takes so long to get to know that
driver where it's not like
you know they're not cheering for me
because i was you know grew up in
illinois
i sound like illinois on my side because
of it
you have to get to know somebody through
their personality and interviews and
you know sometimes in heated situations
but whatever it is that's how you get to
know us so um
so with that said is there anything in
particular you want to mention that's
totally anything you've never said
before
and it would be um controversial
or i'm just kidding um you know me well
enough
i think i'm pretty uh transparent you
are you are
you are um so okay so i kind of wanted
to
go back to the very beginning of us as
teammates okay
when i got to know you and how
you know you're a joker you're funny you
you boys would play your pranks back in
the day of course
my favorite one was where you and daario
who was it it was you dario franchitti
um
right and brian herta all [ __ ] in dan
weldon's toilet and
wasn't that in japan in japan and then
you cranked the heat
and we took the water out of the toilet
that was the first time it's a clutch
move everybody went
how did you organize that so that was
actually a debate
which i'm i'm not picky about that stuff
so i can go to the bathroom anywhere
that i really like and any time
apparently
yes and wow that's that's i think you
have ibs but
you know but then then dario gets oh no
i gotta go first i'm like guys whatever
figured out so we emptied the toilet
it's kind of disgusting conversation
and we took we closed the water yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
flushes so it was no
oh my god and he couldn't flush it oh my
god and
four guys went i was the last one which
wasn't pleasant
yeah that's pretty intense and we
cranked the heat on
in this bedroom and we left so the way i
got the key i actually
impersonated that i was then welded in
japan they didn't know better
then wasn't that famous yet so that's
how i got his room kick
without being asked for an id
it was funny it was back in the day
before they needed your blood type and
correct your passport number and
everything just the other day i locked
myself out of my room
in the hotel and obviously i didn't have
my i don't carry my id
with him with me i went to grab some ice
and
she wouldn't i didn't remember my room
number as you know
i mean i it took me a little bit because
we stay like you know when you stay like
three nights in a row in three different
hotels yeah like where can't remember
where you are when you wake up
and she wouldn't give me a kiss well
we're probably gonna have to go up there
with me so i can prove it because i
can't
i'm not just walking in here and trying
anyway but yeah that was the probably
the
the biggest prank yeah so the point of
the question and that fantastic story is
is i don't feel like you guys pranked me
no but we you know
like here's the thing i mean
you come to the team and and you know
you're this little girl
and and you're stronger you have a
really
strong personality kind of intimidating
at times and you're like
is she gonna hit me if i do something
but also
we got told that you know remember boys
are boys and i know nowadays you i know
you wait a minute you guys got your
wings clipped
you can totally take it but we're like
guys you have to like
don't you can do stuff for to her but
do not exaggerate the way you guys do
her toilet
yeah so and then uh you know then you
you just like you're you used to get
fiery so we're like we backed off we're
like uh we'll leave her alone do you
feel like i've tamed down
a little bit am i more calm than i than
i
was when you remember meeting me and in
the beginning no
i could no just about different things
right i think you'll learn
how to control yourself a little more
obviously as
years goes by i think you've learned but
also you know nowadays
you probably know that a lot better than
me once you're in the spotlight you
gotta unfortunately think about
three times once before you really react
and i think back in the days
the good part was you didn't care you
know you didn't like something
yeah you're gonna go after that well i
mean i used to
i did used to i mean i used to fly off
the handlebars all the time i remember
the one time i was walking down pit lane
the race was still going on it was
michigan we were delayed for like three
hours because of the rain
and then all of a sudden it was drivers
through your cars and we were green
flagging 15 laps and it was the second
longest race of the year next to the
indy 500
and um i i think we sat in the car for
45 minutes before we even rolled off
because they were still trying to dry
weepers and
i wasn't brave enough to get out and go
to the bathroom because i thought sure
enough they're going to
call us to go and um but anyway um
and i remember i i think i ran out of
gas like six laps to go
and i was so pissed off and i was like
throwing my helmet down my earpiece is
down i'm walking down mid-lane and i
kick a barrel
and the barrel was empty and i thought
it was full of water and i was like oh
[ __ ] and i picked the barrel up and i
stood it up straight cause i was like oh
no but
i mean like i said you probably would do
differently today so i think
maybe you haven't changed maybe i mean i
don't think you have
maybe you know sometimes you go yeah
i've learned that
i'm still you're still going to have a
chat you still you're still danican my
in my opinion you still
if we piss you off you're still going to
come after us anyway
was there anyone fiery in your family
was there anyone that like growing up
you were like whoa don't cross
oh my mom perfect i'm so glad that you
said 100
because um so what's interesting is that
of course like we know each other really
well i wouldn't even need to
uh look there's a research team and so
there's 20 pages of notes on you and i'm
like oh cool i'm going to read
them all so i came across a story about
how you your mom found out that you were
racing
and i was like that is the funniest
story and
and and what an interesting story about
perspective
so the story in in paraphrasing would be
like
so you can tell it go so obviously
dad mom was always scared about racing
and that stuff and that and i used to
watch races together all the time and
she's like don't you dare giving this
kid anything that
has four wheels in the steering wheel so
sure enough dad went behind her back and
bought me a go cart and we start going
every weekend going to the go-kart track
and that would make an excuse
to say i don't remember exactly what he
would tell my mom well we're gonna go
to so-and-so's house we're gonna go do
this so anyway
four or five weekends in a row my mom is
like hmm what's going on here yeah well
it was all day all weekend probably
like all day saturday yeah like saturday
from nine to five you know and you're
like
so but it's funny because you think
about it like you said so
your mind my mom is extremely fiery
uh a very jealous person was always
jealous about my dad
and like you know so like what are you
doing where are you going paranoid
yeah and then all right i know that
person
she uh she we get home one day and she's
like
she sat him down i've heard it
afterwards obviously i wasn't part of
that conversation but my mom thought my
dad was cheating on her and using me as
an
alibi because he was being you know gone
every weekend kids as pawns
never fair exactly so which actually
worked i know he
i think he planned that so well dennica
because when
do you think he planned it no no i'm
saying like no i'm saying like it worked
out for him because
he can't imagine that she's thinking the
worst and then you go no i gave the kid
a go-kart and actually
she goes ah well okay all of a sudden it
was okay for me to raise so he
it worked out for him perfect so i read
that and i was like man
the thing that came to mind first was
like perspective
right perspective creates expectation
levels
so she while she
damn well didn't want you to have four
wheels and four tires and a steering
wheel
and said don't you dare get him one of
those all of a sudden now it's totally
oh that was like
because given the contrast of the
situation like oh of course go-karts
totally fine get two
correct um i have your sister do it too
um
but uh but i found that to be so funny
and that's how my racing started
actually we laugh about this
up until today and my mom hasn't changed
a bit and
she's too jealous about me and my sister
and
where does she live she lives in rio
okay in brazil
so how often do you see her she comes
here three times a year yeah um
you know it works she come for the 500
so she no she doesn't she doesn't watch
races
she doesn't watch a single race of mine
what
ever she praised the entire time and she
asked my sisters from from like uh
she came to the 500 three times staying
on my bus
with the tv off just praying the entire
time so
uh she gets nervous so she will come
here and uh
yeah she come here in july for a month
uh she comes here for
christmas and new year's we alternate
between myself and my sister yeah
and now we followed the kids so she what
does that i mean how does that make you
feel that she's never watched you race
i i get it i mean now that i have kids i
i don't know if i was going to be able
to watch my kids
and i have a lot more knowledge than my
mom no offense to her i mean i've known
what
you know what we go through so i don't
mind i think it was something that
she always did and for her it works
so i don't mind it's not that i want her
i mean yes you don't feel offended
or you don't feel like you know and then
she watches you know when like
one race is probably you know she's so
actually she'll go back and watch them
will she go down anymore
she'll never have watched you you know
she won't ever watch your
indy 500 win from 13. no she doesn't
never did it's interesting
wow does she think maybe that now if she
watches one it'll be like
total bad luck like it's like when you
go down a road so long with superstition
right then all of a sudden you break it
and your mind becomes overwhelmed with
the
with the contrast she won't tell me that
but i'm pretty sure that's probably what
goes through her head
you know but she's never going to see
your race
[Laughter]
just fine she's not missing a lot
nowadays
[Laughter]
well racing goes through its ebbs and
flows right like i think about my first
time i come
i came to you know when my first year in
in the indycar series and
my first year at the indy 500 and how
you know
my car was so fast and like everything
was like i
everything was in line like the right
team right engine right car
right everything but here i am with you
know less than a thousand laps
you know a thousand laps of less than
thousand laps of experience in an indy
car in race condition and how
damn it if i could just go back with all
this experience then
i'd have done such a better job um but
um
you know it wouldn't have been the
dramatic story but would you watch your
kids race you said you might not
i don't know i don't think i'm gonna
give them that option so no
they're not gonna race oh really
i don't know i'm kidding my 11 year old
leo which you gave him a go-kart by the
way
um danica welcome as a baby present
her and her dad gave my kid a go-kart
and he was three months old not even
like three weeks old
yeah but everyone does such a bad
night's too have a bad job with kid
presents they give him
presents that are only good for like
right then i was planning for the future
for you i agree
and actually i still have it he drove it
once did he really yeah when he was like
five did you have to like buy a whole
new engine probably and
no at the time no because he wanted to
try and then actually
leo wasn't into it so i still have it so
deco my four-year-old that's
really into it crazy crazy little dude
he actually uh you know knows
every brand of every car he talks about
it you walk in on the street go so that
that's a corvette that's a mercedes so
he might be the one so i don't know i
mean i'm not going to
prevent well you've probably given them
that a pretty good opportunity to get
educated given the fact that you have
how many how many cars no actually i'm
down can you be honest about this or is
this
is this morse no private information
we we grow the family so i had to sell a
lot of the cars
as you remember i had actually up to
like 14 cars
now i'm down to five so
in a meeting do you have a place in
miami still no they just sold that in
december we moved full-time
uh to indianapolis and uh actually i
live
probably six minutes from your dad's wow
lawrence from indianapolis so we we
decided that when i signed with aj
um part of my idea was that i need to be
more involved with the running of the
team as well so i met in the team every
day
so i never enjoyed that yeah like that
whole part of being around
i did it because like that's what you're
expected to do
but i i didn't i was zero productive i
mean in nascar we had
we had meetings like we had monday or
tuesday meetings like some teams were
different but
we had monday meetings and we'd go in
and we talked about the car for a few
hours
and you know that was the most
productive thing i could do other than
that it's literally like
hanging out so are you doing more than i
do a lot more than that i mean i
participated a lot they give me a lot of
freedom to
to help too so it's kind of like i kind
of enjoyed that side i think
as i'm getting towards the end of my
career i'm still
you know people ask me which like you
got that
question a thousand times what's
i was never the type of guy that playing
you know as as
as a racer you know you don't how can
you play i'm gonna plan to win the 500
you can't plan that you can prepare for
it but you can't so
um that's something that i kind of
enjoyed it's still probably going to
keep me around racing if
if i decide when i decided do you want
to be
yeah i mean i don't want to be a team
owner
i don't know that sounds like i mean
like i don't want to know worrying about
the money coming in
hiring and firing no uh but part of
helping
structure a team getting the people i
love working with people
and yeah you know the way you're a
people person yes yes
i mean kind of you know and you are and
and
and and to me i mean look at the people
that i brought if you look at the team
today i have scott harner that was with
mia ganassi he was the general manager
ganassi now he's running our team
eric cotton my engineer that was there
when we were there
and i have four of four of my eight
mechanics that
when i won the 500 they are in my card
so
wow we're bringing so that's people
that's like you gotta feel good story
like i did at the end of our career like
where i was like
oh man i'm back and some of the same
people are back and
numbers and that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean anything that's just
one of my one of my my um
commitments to aj was we're gonna try to
build the team and a strong
team and try to actually raise the bar
and
we've been struggling a lot yeah but but
anyway i've i've enjoyed that part
that's why we moved to indiana
i think that having goals is something
that is critical
to to accomplishing anything right if
you don't know where you want to go
how are you ever going to get there so i
can't leave without a goal
if i don't wake up in the morning thing
i got i i feel i'm i'm not alive
so it makes me you know in in in reading
through all the information and also
knowing that your dad passed away when
you were you know pretty young
and how you you promised him you'd keep
racing yeah that was kind of you know
yes that was that like how
how did that fuel you was that was that
it or was it just because you love
racing like what you know because
it really it really feels like that was
something that you guys had together
you spent time together you obviously
had your dirty little secret from mom
for a while
but you know five weeks you promised him
yeah i mean
dad got sick he got uh diagnosed with
cancer
um when i was nine and he passed when i
was 13.
i was already racing and i think it was
something that we've done
a lot obviously it was four years before
he passed
i raced every weekend you did exactly
the same thing with your dad
and through the years obviously through
the end
when he probably figured out he was not
going to make it which
i didn't realize that i was 13 you never
wanted to believe you're going to lose
your dad of course
regardless how bad i'm 37 i'm not
thinking about that exactly you
shouldn't
nobody should um but he kind of like
prepared myself
for it says hey if i'm not around you
know eventually you have to take care of
your mom and your sister and i think
you're really good in what you do you
shouldn't
give up racing and
uh he was in the hospital on a thursday
it was just a thursday night races are
always on the weekend i had qualifying i
had a test on friday qualify southern
race on sunday so i went to see him in
the hospital thursday night
he wanted to see me ask my mom can he go
pick him up and we sat down
he was totally fine i mean obviously
extremely weak from the chemo and
everything but he was talking and we're
chatting he goes
promise me one thing i said yes whatever
you need what do you want he says
he will never stop racing um
regardless what happens to me never i
mean you know what i mean never
the king raised until i'm seven years
old but i'm almost there you're on your
way
exactly i knew you're gonna do that um
so i said okay then of course you know
and i didn't think anything of it so
i went home that night he passed oh my
god so
i woke up mom was home which is it was
extremely unusual and i'm like what
happened so she sat me down she says
look
you then went to sleep and you started
he started to have some uh you know he
was starting to get delirious he was
really weak and
uh his two last words it was
tony and the gokar race i was like wow
okay
i went i woke up and i went to the track
i went to the track and i tested i
qualified on paul and i won that race on
sunday so
in brazil the service the way it goes
it's really quick we don't do here like
i learned in america it takes a
week right for people when they passed
and in brazil it's kind of like
you want to get that done so this people
stop suffering what do they do to the
bodies and
do they do the same thing but it's just
quick like he passed
between thursday so it was friday yeah
they prepare the bodies put they do the
service saturday boom bury them on
sunday
so i've never actually i didn't go to
the services i didn't want to see it
i didn't believe there was anything that
i wanted to see there i didn't want to
have that image of my dad
laying on the casket looking different
the last time i saw him it was i talked
to him
so i went and i raced and i won the race
so that trophy my mom still has it in
her nightstand
it's a little gold cart right obviously
trophy but
and ever since yes i think uh a lot of
the times because from that time on
it wasn't just pretty right i mean it
gets
you have times that you want to give up
you have times that you're like why do i
do this
you have times that you go my first
question you know you have a tendency
hopefully
like i said it's it's i asked myself why
right
if if people believe in god or not i
mean i've i
do and then i would ask god why why me
and that's very it was very naive or
very selfish
for me to ask that but you know you're
13 you're thinking about and then and
then you go beyond and so you know what
i promised him that and
i think i'm good in what i do so i'm
gonna keep
going and then every time i had a hard
time that i thought about giving up i
remember that i promised him
i wasn't going to and that's why i'm
here today so hopefully
wherever he's at he's super powerful
that that to me is
you know there's a big old word called
you know neuroplasticity about like
retraining your brain
and every day or every difficult time
turned into a shift in power because you
went from a negative to a positive
and you remembered what you promised and
you said i'm gonna do this and instead
of like
going down a hole and not being able to
get back out you said i'm going to do
this
and like that is a powerful thing that i
feel like
is of is applicable in any situation
with any problem
is having that and telling yourself
you're going to do that it's like
i'm thinking of a funny story of like
the very first time no it was the only
time i think maybe you drove my car it
was at the 500
and i was super unhappy i'm like this
thing's a piece of [ __ ] it's horrible
anyone can get in this car and it'll be
horrible and you got in and you went out
and
and and because your freaking mindset
when you get in the car
is i go flat out and turn one for lap
one and you go by
and you go flat out and turn one in my
car
which does not fit you piss you off and
you
uh it was a little short on the back did
it did it feel good though
well it was two things right like i i i
just want to make sure that i wasn't
right no
no you're not and then again i mean you
remember we the the relationship
we had in that team was extremely unique
i think i can say that yeah
maybe yeah it was very we we worked
together yes
and and it was two things that went
through my mind first of all
i knew you well enough and i knew you
had to build your confidence and then i
knew if i had to go on through turn one
flat out i was going to piss you off so
bad
that i didn't matter how bad that car
was you're gonna do it
so i also had to like but i said how
about if i crash this freaking thing
you know i'm gonna have to give her my
car but as soon as i left the pits and
then the cars had the same setup i knew
was in your head
obviously i had more experience than you
at the time and i was like
there is no way i mean but i'll give her
the benefit of the doubt but
obviously you leave the pits you go to
turn three and four with my experience
and i said you know what it's not that
i'm done
and i went flat i know you did i know
you did
but that's that's your mindset and and
by the way thank you for that yeah um
uh and i did i went out you didn't thank
me enough if you don't have imagine
magically felt much better after that
you must have tuned it right
uh unless i got the tire pressures right
um but you know that that is your
mindset like i feel like when you get
set on something
you do it what's the next thing like
what do you what's the next do it and
that's what i'm saying the next thing
is it's i i've never
the way i grew up was always uh you know
with
whatever i put my mindset to do it which
you can relate to that because i know
you've done it you prove it you made it
in a very tough
sport that at the time man was just it
was a mansport
um i'm gonna do it so what's next
to make this team competitive and and
and you know i've been taking a lot of
heat
um it's funny that we're talking about
this because you took a lot of heat in
your life the bigger you become
the more critics you have um
and and it's just it's my mindset i
really no disrespect to anybody that has
an opinion about me you're totally
entitled to it
um oh he's washed out he's 44. he can't
drive it anymore
this is my mindset this is what i want
to do i i
respect your opinion but i really don't
care
this is what i want to do if you still
feel like you can get up on that horse
and go 240 miles an hour then
damn it you can exactly because the day
that you don't want to
like when i got towards the end like i
look back now and i'm thinking
haley who's worked for me forever you
know haley she sent me a one-year post
photo of me standing by the car with
my sister's little girls and i sent a
message back going i'm so glad it's not
i'm so i said it's so glad it's 2019.
because it's scary as [ __ ] i mean you
haven't arrived at that place
but what what we what i did what we did
what you still do it's crazy as hell it
is
but but i don't know any other way so
basically i i was having
you know more and more as the years go
by you
have those type of conversations either
in an interview
or at home laura's like dude you have
four kids
yeah what does she say about that we
have you know gladly thank god we have
more money than we thought we could have
we don't
it's not about the money it was never
about the money which is why you're
successful yeah we never i mean i never
thought about that yeah we're like oh
i'm going to race because i want to be
rich
that that was you're attaching yourself
to the wrong outcome to manifest that to
happen
exactly so i said you know
it's one of those things the day that i
wake up
and i think like like you said the
shit's so dangerous i don't want to do
it
i'm probably yeah going to stop and
and and the question the the i just had
this conversation last week with her
because we're getting to a point that
she's like but
when is that no she asked me she says
how about
what are you planning are you doing like
dp did we call her dp because
anyway would you announce your
retirement
and go through uh
like a season that everybody i don't
know i'm very emotional i went to your
farewell party and i was crying myself i
was balling
no but but not as much as i would
probably even be able to speak so
i said i don't know i haven't decided
that i don't think i
i might wake up i don't know i might
wake up tomorrow
and i'm gonna say this is my last race i
don't care if it's three races to go
five races to go if if i feel like i'm
not doing this
i'm not the type of guy uh no i'm gonna
sit there and
drive at 230 miles an hour just because
i have commitments to people
it's it's so you stay like like you have
and i'm sure like me like you just stay
attached to this process and you stay
attached to the job and it is what it is
and you're moving forward and
you know um i mean i can't even say that
i got excited about the season to start
because i knew it was coming like
yes i'm i'm happy for it but it's not
like i'm like itching to get back in the
car again
and so when in 2017 when my sponsor left
which
you know you've been around long enough
to see me why it happened to me twice i
i haven't
like that was a new problem for me and
so you you get fate like
i for the first time was faced with the
scenario of like what if they
what if they just fire me what if you
know especially nascar with
gigantic budgets like what if they just
let me go
and then i had this rush of feeling of
like i'm not ready
and i'm telling you it felt really good
because i didn't think like that i
didn't think like oh my god i'm excited
i'm ready let's do this so i'm racing
it's the best
because he was comfortable right it was
comfortable and and and then
right and and and also you know you you
get put in that squeeze position where
you're like
what do you feel and i felt oh [ __ ] i'm
not ready
and it felt really good to feel that but
here's the problem it planted a seed
and so this is my experience in
retirement anyway
that's good i'm getting it i'm getting
that yeah
but it planted the seed of like but
but like not just like the idea in a
distant way and not
feeling into that because that's the
magic of like feeling into something
like you
feel into being successful or winning or
retiring or whatever you have to like
feel the emotions and
and imagine your life without it right
so i started imagining where would i go
what would i do where would i live what
would i
you know all these scenarios running
through my head these these like further
scenarios than just the concept of
retiring
and i was like man
that's not so bad but see but that's why
i looked at it you know and i talked
obviously i'm talking to you i talked to
michael andretti i talked to the junior
about it i talked to tony stewart about
it um
just as a as a casual conversation yeah
and
i'm not afraid of that and in in a way
i'm not the type of person that like i
just said
i'm like what's next i know i will find
something
yeah you know so to me it's still
i think you know through the years when
i had you remember when i left andretti
my sponsor left and they fired me and i
had five years into my contract
and i had to go and figure it out so i
went back home to brazil
found a bunch of sponsors came back and
you still wanted it three years later i
won the 500
yeah and then i went to ganassi which it
was a big team and then like you were
like a lot of pressure the champion and
i had a tough tough tough teammate dixon
i mean there was a chip
and chip and and the pressure and the
pressure got into me
and and the pressure to perform and i
think to be honest
during those four years i've i've
thought about retirement because i
i was getting beat not just on the
racetrack but mentally and people are
trying well this is how you got to drive
like scott dixon this is the car dixon
drives fast
how can i set guys let me put it this
way
if i was able to just copy what he does
then then it will be easy or anybody
anybody anybody that has a good car
everybody's gonna what we're gonna
[ __ ] bring sorry we're gonna freeze
you can swear
all you want finish four guys whatever
okay thank you so and that really got
into me
and so my last year aganassi i told chip
in his face that i
i knew i didn't do a good job for him
and then i shouldn't be there because
for some reason it wasn't clicking and
that's when it was what's next
and i'm like do i want to keep racing or
not and then i meet aj
is like aj says hey come on let's let's
build this team
so that's my fire so you had a new goal
it's a new goal it's a new goal it's a
team that
hasn't finished that last in the
championship right now again the sponsor
is getting excited because they're
getting
because they're like you're like lebron
and cleveland when he came back
i wish i wish i hope i can do that but
it was it is kind of that you know what
i mean like in my mind was like you know
what this is what i want to do and i
remember because larry ford came to me
and says
why are you in a race for me you know
like you're
i mean you're tony kanaan i'm like
exactly i
i'm just a normal race car driver and i
want to make you guys successful so
last year yeah you were there and
we led a bunch of laps yeah at the 500
and then
they were trilled so basically that's
why i'm doing it so
yes do i love racing a hundred percent
uh
do i feel like you sometimes that you
know man i gotta travel
man i got the hotels and the buses and
like i i have to pull [ __ ] that goes
on
exactly i have to police myself exactly
hey
don't forget don't forget you got to say
abc supply chain
my sponsor i was so bad i had to go to
media training after like i was in indy
car driving yeah
because in in i have like a mold enough
now that i can say guys
i am not doing this yeah i will plug you
guys in
but it's not i'm not going to start my
interview my number 14 car with abc
supply
chevy firestone
that's not happening yeah i it's not my
style yeah um
i haven't done it in years i think my
fans know i mean
i've always you know it's funny because
let's say i've no i've known you for so
long
and then i go see an interview and i'm
like
that's that's [ __ ] up that's not her
they are telling her what to do
yeah just to begin the interview after
that you become yourself but you're like
yes my uh you know go daddy yeah come on
guys
yeah you know and then everybody's the
same so you're watching that you're like
really man
i always felt like they interview me
because i don't do that
exactly right because you're interesting
because you're controversial or because
you say what you want you answer the
damn question
and so when you change into the person
to serve your sponsor that just says the
names
they're not going to want to talk to you
anymore so so what now i'm not a
valuable
commodity or i don't help help your
bottom line because i'm not on tv
look at my damn suit it's right here
right here right all over the place
i agree yeah so i i mean i stand stand
your ground don't you lose that fire hey
i'm 44.
they ain't changing it it's only getting
worse i feel like the fire is just dying
the more and more i do it whatever the
hell i want
you know it gets to the point that it's
just not so anyway but that was
that's what gets me going yeah that's
what you know i still want to do it and
and
yes i can assure you that
i don't probably i don't have more than
two years left
yeah on myself and then i keep telling
my friends that too and i will ask you
as well as a friend
um because it's hard you know when you
see an old person driving a car on the
street and they're all over the place
but they still think they can drive
scottsdale of course i see old people
driving
cars so i'm asking my friends my close
friends
if you if i'm doing that on the race car
that i'm not good enough anymore and you
guys
see that please pull me aside discretely
and tell me that yeah i think it's one
of those things
where you just have to you know i i
i don't know if it's one of those things
where you wake up one day and you
realize because
you're going to have to think different
for that to happen or something is going
to have to happen and you don't want
something to happen that's bad because a
lot of times that's what it's going to
be
right and so you kind of want to
just check in on some levels so like
what um you know that kind of leads me
to another topic that is such a
i think an important one and you talked
about how with ganassi
you know you were getting beat into the
ground and you were it's a lot of
pressure and you know just kind of kind
of like zap the fun out of it a little
bit
what what things do you do and then just
to rephrase that like
i was beating myself down with the
pressure nobody was there they were too
that's me saying it but
you know that's me tony did not say that
no no no you know how he goes
yeah well you know you know you have a
good car so you put the pressure on your
teammate weaning championships and
you're like
so you put the pressure on yourself of
course of course and that is the
expectation level too
you know so you know it's coming from
both sides but you know the self one is
the most important one so right so let's
keep on the self so what did you do
to counter that like i had certain
things over time that i had to do but
what like what did you do
to did you even know that you had to
counter that with certain
so okay well not 100 i've got
somebody my wife made me aware of it and
the only way
unfortunately the way i got presented
was
i was being an extremely miserable human
being
at home with my wife with
my kids what does that i i know
i know the happy go lucky time what's
the miserable tony
extremely moody uh very short and
i wouldn't i'm i'm i wasn't rude to them
but i wasn't present
nothing it would excite me oh let's go
to the pool
whatever in the pool and i'll be in the
pool sitting there like
you could have gone to the doctor they'd
definitely give me pills for sure so
so she grabbed me one day and she says
look i
i don't know if you want how you take
this because i don't
you know there's one thing about tony i
would listen to your criticism but that
doesn't mean i would accept it really
well i
don't like it uh i'm working on that
but so anyway we sat down and she's like
just look at you
um i wanna she went all the way back
all the way back to my childhood and
look what look what you became
look the family that you have look what
we have
look at your kids and so i'm not saying
for you to like yeah if you don't want
to be grateful for that it's totally
fine it's your choice
i'm trying to show you so you can look
around
and maybe you can see some happiness
it's you're not
the way she put it it touched me so hard
she says
we're okay the one that is not okay the
one that is missing
it's you we're not missing anything
we miss we miss you but the kids are
still happy they still have fun
i still have fun i still love my kids i
still love my life you're missing it
so i have to say i cried and yeah
and and that hit me pretty hard and then
i said you know what so that's what you
realize the work was on you
correct right which is always the
hardest thing you want something else to
fix it somebody else to fix correct
and as a race car driver you blame on
the car you blame on the team the best
part about the job is you can blame the
car
exactly you know so you know like
it's just it's not like basketball or
football if you throw a bad ball
you threw it like you hit it's your
fault no that was my guy that didn't
give me you can't do that
so anyway so the racket's the same it's
supposed to hit the ball that's the same
that goes over it didn't make it over
the net i can't help him
so i i i said all right um i thought
about it
um and and that was probably the first
time that i said
do i need to give up racing to be happy
that was my first question and
follow up right after that says well no
because i'm not happy because my racing
is not good
so where's the balance and that's when i
decided that i was not going to stay
where i was
although i had good friends there i
became really close to dixon and
and but it was a it wasn't a good
environment for me it was putting a lot
of pressure on myself
but i wanted it to keep racing but at
this time at this point of my
career i had gone from winning the 500
to one of the top teams
and in the car with a teammate that was
extremely tough extremely talented it
has won five championships or three
since i signed his nickname is the
iceman exactly
um so i wasn't really getting hired
by another top team i'm 42 years old
you're basically right you're doing all
about one of them you're just like guys
we used
tony you had a good one thank you you
had a great one
really yeah stop you think i realized
maybe
so i'm like all right so and i looked
around and i said well what
what's next and then i said well that is
aj same thing i did with kv when i left
andretti we we
we built the team and so i signed a
three-year deal with him which is i'm in
the middle of my second year
and we're talking about maybe an extra
one and that would be it but
i knew for a fact when i signed with him
that was going to be my last contract so
are you telling me that
you found a new goal is that what you
know
well was that the self-worth i mean what
was that what was it
you know when lauren had that heart to
heart with you so beautifully
you know what was it that you what did
you do something has to change in your
in your routine or in your mindset my
mindset
my mindset has to change right and i had
to actually start it
to start to separate again my racing
life to my personal life
right although i'm not good at it
obviously i got called on it
um i've i had to find a new goal
in my profession to be able to be happy
on my personal life as a transition
because i don't think that's right
and you should separate things sure
although i'm still allowed
to come home and and and be mad at her
or mat with her and say please just let
me be bad because i can't be mad at
those guys because with a caveat you can
say anything you want it's like with all
due respect
anything and she and she's like yeah go
ahead let it go but just
i've learned i had to relearn how to
enjoy
my life even because because you go from
winning a lot
of not winning and then you're
questioning yourself of course right oh
my god you questioned yourself it's like
you know i mean am i good enough that i
do because everybody's saying i'm not
you know so but you know that's not true
but it is easy for those thoughts to
creep in when things aren't going as
well you think to yourself
well is it me have i lost something you
do right and then
you run down that you go down that whole
rabbit hole on yourself
and that's a dangerous place to go
because those are such negative thoughts
it is so then you have to you obviously
started thinking positive so the first
thing
i did like i'm tony [ __ ] like i am
amazing
correct right but actually the only
thing i've did
was i didn't know how i could change
that in my job because if i was going to
relay
on results i wasn't going to the right
team let's face it we're building the
team so the results are not going to
come
if i'm going to say oh no i need to win
a race to be happy that was going to be
a problem
so i've changed my attitude at home
first
and then like what'd you do i mean these
are these are things
i woke up honestly after that
conversation i woke up i said i have to
be different
so obviously it wasn't a switch but
i would pay more attention during the
day when i was being negative to myself
and i was affecting
other people and instead to go
[ __ ] i gotta wake up seven in the
morning and these kids are gonna be
yelling they're gonna be
crying they're gonna eat their breakfast
and they have to brush their teeth
then i gotta put them in the car and i
gotta take them to squint they're gonna
fight who's gonna open the door of the
car and
you go you know what and lauren is
completely the opposite you know my wife
um you've known her since the day we met
she laughs about everything the kid
they threw a cracker through like the
table
i'm like you can't do that oh look at
the new artwork on the wall honey
relax so i've i've started to learn that
and you
enjoy more even the bad stuff you know
like okay
well because honestly we get spoiled you
know that
yeah we we become celebrities in a way
everything works we
get to a restaurant we don't wait we
like oh my god this and that so i'm like
i want to become a little bit more
normal
which moving to indy wasn't a big help
because everybody knows me here but
so i started to enjoy that and
eventually things
started to change and and i start to see
good things on that and then
i start to enjoy my work and i start i
start to enjoy being at home
and and look at myself out so i think we
we kind of get carried on and
and look back and see you know what what
about the people that wake up
four in the morning and have to do that
and still go to work for 10 12 hours a
day like i don't know behind the counter
or
they hate their jobs no windows no no no
no
no they come home and they still they
can't make ends meet at the end of them
i'm like
yeah just all that came and and yeah
it's like to me um
and then i went back to brazil that
we're talking about two years ago
ever since that conversation and and i
do a lot of charity things there and
we have a foundation that we help um
kids that
have no moms and nor dads or got
abandoned and we do christmas for them
and we buy a bunch of the gifts and
then you start getting back you just get
that stuff back and you go you know what
i don't have it that bad
just because my racing is not okay but
you but you have to see it right you
have to go
the first step is identifying so you go
oh i have
no i get to oh it's gonna it might be a
wonderful day like back in the indycar
days when
you know things were a little relentless
for me too um haley and i had this whole
kittens and rainbows thing i don't know
if you ever heard about it but we were
like she'd knock on the bus door to come
get me to do interviews before we'd go
to the go to the trailer for
for meetings and and she'd be like hello
good morning it's kittens and rainbows
today
and we just like ham it up and not
because we were feeling that way but
because we had to
force ourselves to feel that way so the
first thing is like
you can either fake it till you believe
it which really does work
or you can identify the times where
you're being negative and flip it
and then through that repetition you
probably
naturally were just in a happier state
because
you trained yourself to switch it which
so having the negative is
fine but you have to recognize that you
had it then then switch it and think oh
no i get to do this my life is wonderful
and then over enough time it just
gradually becomes the dominant
emotion and i think that is two things
one is
you look at yourself and you go how bad
you really
have it you know we have we we're in a
sport that is extremely selfish so you
become selfish you think
everything it's you you and you start
you know you get married or you have a
boyfriend or
you have a family then you go
well it's not all about me yeah yeah did
kids change that a lot for you to think
or was it or was it more
like life experiences yeah you know they
say kids are i don't have kids you know
the kids did change a lot because you
know they're innocent people
especially when they're little and they
tell you the truth
right in your face so sometimes you get
home and you don't have time to debate
about that race because you're just
there with
you know watch looking or you go watch
the
i don't have time when you come home
they're like daddy it's so good to see
you exactly and they hug you hey they
want to play do you want to play
choo-choo train with me
or you want to then you go yeah and then
they go it's not like you said uh did
you see how i did today exactly
are you sure you still love me you know
of course not so the other the best line
my four-year-old told me the other day
says dad when you didn't used to suck
[Laughter]
because he hasn't seen me win the race
it's been four years so
i said yeah that go when i didn't used
to suck we used to win a lot of races
on the on the green car right i
but you know that keeps you you know you
laugh and you go yes
so that that you know it's nowadays
it's it's uh i'm not saying i don't have
bad moments i don't want to sit here
yeah no that's you that's being human
you know i changed it changed my life
and well if you never have a negative
thought
but i go to the track and i enjoy living
and i think
because i know i'm getting towards the
end yeah i'm trying to enjoy
every moment so we came here today
yeah i'll give you a perfect example
yeah my guy benito
it's your haley it's been with me
forever
messed up the date three years ago
he would hear all day long i'll be mad i
would be like
so we said that you're in here you're
actually because you're not supposed to
be here yeah
i said with with david and we said oh
here we go let's do this
i actually had deco with me he wanted it
to meet you
he was watching he's so honest he's like
no this is better
home is better i want to play with my
cars go ahead
and i said all right well can we do this
can we arrange let's go back
oh and i come back in an hour yeah if it
was before i'll be mad i'll be yelling
at him the entire way home you
[ __ ] up come he can't do that at this
point
whatever man we're still having a great
conversation i have
400 other things to do after this
because i got to go to the speedway for
some parties but
yeah i learned that again
it still gets to me sometimes of course
but it takes a lot longer nowadays
yeah than they use well that's a
beautiful flow and you kind of just
never
and that's a it's like a common word
that i think to myself is flow because
it's those times when things don't go
right that either oh my god you have a
fantastic story
or it leads you to a place that you
wouldn't have been or you maybe you know
it's the whole butterfly
butterfly effect or sliding doors sort
of um
thing where you know if this didn't
happen these others wouldn't and you
just have to respect
that dynamic in life and that you know
it's all
leading you to where you need to go and
and of course you have to do your best
right like
benito will definitely be double
checking the uh trust me
extremely american dates of four five
five but trust me i think he felt more
bad that i actually said
many it's all right you're allowed to
make a mistake but please don't do it
again
instead of yelling at him yeah just
double checking and i would be talking
to him for two days which happened
before
trust me our relationship has improved
as well yeah as i'm pretty sure and
haley get
into each other sometimes she makes you
do things that you know
she said the other day i was arguing
with her on something a little bit and
she goes
she goes dp same team here
and that was exactly [ __ ] that's right
i'm working right on my side
like babies i mean if you don't want to
do any interviews
not my problem it's not going to change
my life you think about it
yeah yeah you know so yeah yeah i mean
i've learned how to relax
that's so good so a one thing that i do
to relax
um that i love for me and i i'm maybe
you're the same like
i love working out well yeah well i do
you know you know me so i but i've never
like there was one time we were at the
gym at the same time it was at uh
uh where was it over off of for
it was like saint vincent no it was at
the speedway remember
in the basement yeah and i don't really
see what you do but you're
super duper fit and you always have been
you've always been
like a very uh lean mean fighting
machine so
like what do you do what do you really
do
too many things nowadays because we have
so many options and i know like
so are you an over trainer because i'm a
total admitted
yeah i mean today more is better can we
say the time here the real time
yeah 4 25
and today i already worked out for four
hours oh my god
i rode my bike for three but row my bike
people don't think i'm just getting
there with my little
basket in my dog joyride no so it was
raining i was supposed to go ride
so you were outside no okay so i woke up
it was raining when we have a group of
guys that we do a hard
hard ride on on saturdays and it was
raining so i got on my trainer and i
rode staring at tv for three hours
and uh what did you watch uh
everything i actually on my list right
now i'm watching the blacklist
which is you know so i have some
some some uh some catch up to do because
i haven't been able to so
if you guys know anything that happened
yesterday i haven't watched that so
please don't tell me
just watch a movie or stuff like that
yeah i do that sometimes too actually
i've
i've
migrated towards not even listening to
music sometimes i'll put on
like a podcast actually that's a youtube
video or something like that
i'm gonna give you a podcast somebody
gave it to me last week
i don't recall the name but when once
we're done i'll look it's actually a
book about
overtraining damn it i don't want to
read that it's a it's a book
i'd rather stand in my lane it's a
podcast actually
anyway but yeah i i so nowadays
um i would say probably i'm in the
best shape i've ever been it's just
because that's saying something buddy
yeah well you know you know i'm not
getting any younger i think and when
you're younger you can
go by and just do the minimum the bare
minimum when you're still there yeah
i'm 100 convinced that that's what's
keeping me you know
still at my job but basically what i do
um
by the way having been gone from indy
cars for seven years
i couldn't turn the wheel the first day
when i had to do the refresher
i was like oh and you're not the type of
person that you stop working out
i'm just i am more fit than i ever was
when i drove indy cars for sure
i do crossfit um i don't ride bike for
fun
but that's that doesn't matter but but i
mean that i was
i'm as strong as i have ever been for
sure and i got in the car and i was like
i can't turn i know the wheel so
[ __ ] over the years so since i've moved
to indy
a year ago in my life it's
pretty boring actually because i i take
the kids
to school every morning if i'm home you
get to take the kitchen i get to take
this i get i want to take the kids with
the minivan which everybody makes fun of
me
please do you do you seriously have a
minivan i drove it here you i mean but
now i didn't because i we swapped cars
but i came here with the minivan can we
take a picture in front of you
yeah black wheels dark windows so they
don't know who's driving but i have it
you know because the most popular
question to ask a race car driver is
what do you drive
they have a minivan so you know the fun
things to answer are like i've got a
lamborghini i've got a ferrari but the
other fun answer is i have a mini van i
do and actually you can't go in the
middle like the tahoe's not going to do
the trick but i have to say
minivan you i don't think you obviously
don't have one but
they do not respect you if you drive
them anyway
if they can't cut you off they will cut
you off if
you know when you're coming like you're
gonna like actually you're fighting for
a lane they go
[ __ ] it's a minivan i gotta get ahead of
it and then they just
they will do whatever they can to like
chop you off i'm like
watch so like i'm driving in the i drive
the minivan every morning
and then i drop the kids at school and i
come home because it's really close and
i'll swap cars because
i get into your ferrari no no i get into
my
towel i love towels but uh but uh
but we swap because actually i go to the
gym and lauren actually picks them up
because the kids are still small they're
little so they
they only go to school for four hours 11
30 they're out and i'm still the gym so
but my life is
and then anyway i get on my own car and
people
don't do the stuff that they just did to
me five minutes ago
so it is a a a a yeah
there is something about the minivan i i
take the kids to school around
eight o'clock um i go to the gym
here in town and do very specific things
um i've
learned i'm trying to to get more
flexible which
i was always the type of guy that lifts
a lot of weights and
getting older i was really like do we
need to do a yoga class when i come back
for that actually
yes uh i uh started lauren is doing it a
lot so i started i can actually
recommend um some stuff to do at home
like an there's like yoga glow is what i
use online and you just
search in like i have 30 minutes or i
have 60 minutes and you're like oh level
level one two three
up on that yeah anyway but it's the
hardest thing i've ever done i mean it's
it's
like i i sucked at it i'm bad at it but
anyway so i go to the gym
um we're doing a lot of new new things
and exciting things at the gym nowadays
i spend two
two and a half hours every morning apart
from lifting
we do a lot of circuit a little bit of
crossfit because i love
but now have you done crossfit oh for
you for six years
oh my god oh yeah that's what we should
do yeah let's go through yoga let's go
to crossfit
but also we have nowadays there's
amazing
uh technology and tvs with that you we
can use for your reflexes
so basically it's this big 72 inch tv
with this computer uh pit fit that you
guys with gym with fitfit
and they put a program in and you have
to hit this little blue balls
as fast as you can in one minute and
then obviously we have
seven drivers that work out at the same
time and so it becomes a competition so
you become better at that
who's that who's the sharpest and who's
the least so
i mean it's just science just science
the fastest one is actually kyo kaiser
which is an indie lights driver
young kid yeah technology you'll be gone
are you surprised
yeah but dixon is still pretty good
that's just his dexterity he's just
really good with the techniques
exactly skids nowadays you know what
millenniums they call right
so then whatever uh to that two and a
half hours in the morning and then i go
for my bike rides uh
for two hours in the afternoon so in a
week i would say
i will do 19 to 20 hours of workouts
so you work out monday tuesday wednesday
thursday if i'm not racing
on every every day do you ever take an
off day no the off day will be something
really easy like a yoga stretch
or a easy cardio just to keep yeah we
call the the the active recovery
recovery which is the biggest [ __ ]
ever it's just code for i don't want to
do nothing it's not good
actually i i i have to say that's why
i'm i'm listening to this podcast of of
you know the recovery because yeah i
don't believe that my body hurts if i
don't work out
like if i take a day off i wake up and i
know
probably is in my mind but i feel pain
here there or my age
well thoughts become things so look i
mean there's a lot worse things to be
thinking
100 then uh oh man if i don't work out
today my body won't
feel good but you know it's just you get
used to it i've done it all my life
so do you so you lift heavy weights then
i mean you're you've always been really
much
twice a week yeah so to to but that's
because i like it yeah right so
the way i structure my workout is
i gotta do everything that i need to do
to be able to drive the race car
which is which is the core the shoulder
the neck
you know the stretching reflex reflex
yeah so that it
that's integrated to every workout i do
got it but once that's done
then what's fun so what's your love then
what's your crossfit
crosstalk oh my god
burpees and you know all the stuff that
i i so
then i do that just because you know for
fun
the cycling the triathlons i do a lot of
triathlons i still see some swimming and
and running
back to crossfit so what are your
favorite moves and what are your least
favorite moves
um i'm still i suck at
you know growing up gymnastics yeah like
anything that has to do with it
so can you do ring muscle ups i can one
or two but i want to do like i'm not
i've i've been able to do them
sporadically but i never commit to
practicing because i'm not like
i hurt my shoulder trying to do it so
i'm actually i haven't done it in
eight months because i'm afraid now that
they fixed it then it was actually
that's the biggest problem right we get
competitive you can do whatever you want
now but why i still driving i can't
hurt myself so i won't be able to drive
the car tony that's what happened with
nascar because it's so much easier
physically i just started doing whatever
i wanted
because i didn't need to be recovered
for the week again because it just
didn't matter
i'm like jimmy how can you run 20 miles
before you get in the car and he's like
why because it's so easy yeah you do
that before you drive a video you can't
wake up in the morning not
super duper smart like when it's
richmond and it's really hot out in the
summer and then it's but
but yeah i mean from a from a from a
muscle but we can't do that in any car
can you drove it last year i mean that
is like
when i drove any cars i was afraid to
hold a magazine for too long
and flip the pages because my forearms
would be fatigued like
i was super careful about overworking
and
being recovered and with nascar i didn't
have to worry about that so
i i can't wait to see what you look like
after being
out of the car for a year yeah it's it's
it's uh you know i don't think i will
do what you did i don't think if i'm
not driving when the day that i i'm
driving long enough
so you think it's just gonna be ice
cream and walks oh that's it
that's it it will not that no no no no
no no
no no i'm saying no no sorry i i thought
you said if i if i
take a year off and i go back in the
race car no no no no no
the day that i retire i'm just honestly
first of all
i'll be 20 pounds heavier muscle wise
because i i just
start lifting i like it i mean yeah i'm
all into my body fat
i hate the way i look right now because
i look like a little little rat
that is you know i want to be bigger the
good news is we have cameras on so
everybody can see that you're not alone
you know
well but i don't want to like take your
like i'm not going to do it but if you
were to show everyone
i would i would take my shirt off but i
think it's you know with all the respect
in another podcast sure everyone can
trust me i went to see the crossfit
games
and froome did you yes man i went last
two years and the guy
like he's my size and he's a hundred
are you talking about rich rich yeah i
know rick you know him i saw pictures
that
you saw him he's my height he's i want
to be that size
i want to be you know i i'm five five
i'm
150 pounds i'm a whim you you know why
you will because you will have
you've already you already know what
it's like to put that many hours in yeah
and
look all you have to do is keep lifting
and eat which i like
well that's the next thing is so rich
never had like a really
so i mean i've seen him you know he's
stayed at the house before like i i
i've seen what he wakes up and has
brought so he would like skip breakfast
and but he would show up usually having
stopped at a
grocery store of some sort and bought
like
pounds of deli meat and some cheese and
then he'd just like snack on that stuff
and
it was like sumo style like big huge
dinner like no breakfast
meat meat meat and cheese say i want to
do that i just
know but now he does now he does now he
is particular because he has ailments
right he has like
you know his you know knees i'm pretty
sure i'll get into like the proper
people
to not to get hurt but yeah i can help
you with all that so
even though you already looked ten times
better than i ever have
that's not but so is there a diet do you
do anything specific with your diet yeah
yeah
yes i i obviously um every year
i do a metabolic test so i know exactly
uh what my body burns if i just lay in
bed all day long
i did a metabolism test but i just did
one where it was like do i have a high
or low metabolism and i was like right
on
right on normal basically my body right
as i got older
i kept dropping i went from
burning 16 uh 16
yeah 1 600 calories a day
to 1200 calories a day um you know as
your heart rate you get older your
metabolism slows down so basically with
that
you go and you put how many calories you
burn a day
average right so the resting is doing
nothing right that's just
it's just it's interesting yeah it's
just being alive yeah they just say if
you just lay in bed all day long you're
gonna burn 1200 so basically
you know you can eat 1200 but if you go
work out i born actually
pretty much 36 to 3800 calories a day
between my workouts and oh is that
including resting
the the 1200 plus plus another 36.
no plus another 20 24
we got it we got it that's why we drive
the cars and we have engineers to figure
out
all the math correct so and with that
then we have i don't call a diet because
i don't like to call diet i call it a
healthy
sure lifestyle yeah leaving yeah right
so
i agree i i allow myself twice a week to
have
a cheat meal which is not a full meal
it's either one dessert
or if i want to have a burger because i
want to have it what's your favorite
dessert i love desserts i love key lime
pies and cheesecakes
so in a cheesecake you go to
the cheesecake factory it's 1600
calories but
but that i don't make that math right so
but usually i'm do you
really eat that many calories in a day
as far as like your resting
and your opera like what you can burn
that's a lot of food i can't because
it's too much food so basically
i i'm allowed to cheat like that but so
but i'm actually extremely
i would call boring uh as far as my
meals go
because you know especially with do you
follow a certain diet of like gluten
dairy no keto i eat everything
never i've never i don't feel bad i
don't
i know some people said oh i've changed
this yeah i went
you know lactose free and i'm awesome
yeah
i never really was a big milk drinker i
drink a lot of
momentum you with more energy could be
dangerous since exactly i don't need it
four hours a day so i drink a lot of
almond milk but i mean i'm
i'm i'm simpler so when we cook at home
because of the lifestyle and it's so
busy
i don't wanna like oh what we're gonna
have today so we cook every sunday laura
and i
we make all the food for the whole week
so ground beef
ground turkey uh you know all the so and
we have it but we have that all week
you know if you come eat in the house
today you're gonna have ground beef and
sweet potato
if you come next week you're gonna have
ground beef and sweet potato so just let
me know what you're having each week
while i'm here
okay i'll bring it to you and we have
the portions and then you know i'm a
little actually a little particular
about that i do
actually weight my food you do scale it
yes so you work but you do
you do macros yes but nowadays obviously
with the travel i'm not bringing a scale
everywhere i go
right i'll go to the rest and say can i
have this uh can i have a spare plate
too so i've learned
i've learned how to how to you know
measure my portion
by visually totally and obviously you're
gonna call lean meat in a restaurant
you're not gonna have it so i'm kind of
you gotta have to be a little bit more
flexible but
obviously i love numbers i'm all about
the body fat i get mad when i'm
over ten percent and and it just
drives me nuts so it's uh i've never
tested for good reason
you shouldn't because it's addicting so
as long as
knowledge is power though right so then
you know you know you're nobody
you know but you should but no you
shouldn't you shouldn't because
my my thing is i'm trying to change that
is if you look yourself in the mirror
and you think you look good it doesn't
matter if you're 20 body fat because
then you look the way
you like the way you look yeah the
problem is perception right exactly
where you know where it was dad cheating
or was it a go-kart perception
but you also don't want to become a
slave of your body because you know like
you get the way people do in pictures
they don't do that all year long
as you know right i do yeah i mean for
the cover of my book i mean
i for for my book pretty intense i
worked out i mean i
worked out a ton all i always work out a
lot but um
but the few months before i started
being really particular about my food
and i carried my food everywhere with me
like everywhere i went i had a cooler
i was very particular i ate a ton of
stuff and i ate lots of food but i was
very particular that it was my prepared
food
and um and then towards the end i got
more and more picky as it came but i
didn't want a crash diet for a month i
wanted
some time but yeah i mean you know those
aren't real you don't look like that
every day walking around and
then and then for what right and for who
so what is it you know
once you get there you realize that
you're like oh now what can you just
everyone just look at me right now real
quick okay yeah i'm gonna go have a
cheeseburger now yeah and then with the
kids it's tough like we're all like the
kids hey dad let's go eat the
cheeseburger yeah
now i'm gonna have a salad so i i i kind
of the reasons why are important
correct but i don't think yeah i think
my wife lauren was telling me that the
other day i think i'll be extremely
dangerous when i have more time to look
at all that stuff a little more hardcore
we're going to work out seven hours a
day instead well
all right well i know i've kept you for
a long time so thank you so much
thanks for being i mean i like to be the
first one yeah you you were you're
you're uh by mistake but it happened
that's okay see that was
that was all by nature it correct jump
right into it and
especially with someone so great as you
and someone that's accomplished so much
and we share so many stories and
and obviously we share a love of
crossfit which i didn't know and anyone
that does crossfit it's like cult we all
know that we're on it i mean we can see
in our hands
yeah after i did my workout program
actually this year the first three
months of the year so getting back to it
i was telling my friend at the gym the
other day i'm like
yeah my hands have to get re-acclimated
she's like oh i bet
so anyway well um all right well let's
thank you i guess i'll see you at the
gym maybe no let's do it we'll do it
we'll do a workout we'll do a wad right
you're going to kick my ass but you make
one up and i'll make one up i can
promise you it's going to have a lot of
burpees so it'll be surprised it'll be
like
like the crossfit games you show up here
and we will okay
sure we should do that and you'll keep
you we will try and keep each other's
work out under 20 minutes each
right like it could be five minutes i
have a feeling you're a fran guy but
um i'm like uh i'm like a 50 filthy 50
girl
okay so all right oh comes 15 minutes
keep it under 15. we'll be throwing up
i'll bow barf for sure
so you guys going to see me barf can't
wait thanks tony thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe
button